place aux femmes maintenant en union
soviétique dans plusieurs pays européens
et pour la première fois en france ce
lundi 8 mars a été officiellement dédié
aux femmes une journée célébrée d'abord
à l'elysée où le chef de l'état avait
convié 450 femmes il aura annoncé les
mesures qui doivent désormais présidé à
l'action gouvernementale
isabelle büchler c'est à ces 4 550
ouvrières employées syndicalistes ou
mères de famille que françois mitterrand
a exposé les grandes lignes de son
action
parmi les options concrètes de son
gouvernement il est mis l'action sur
l'égalité d'accès à tous les emplois de
la fonction publique mais aussi du
secteur privé un projet doit est en
route pour les femmes d'agriculteurs le
gouvernement étudie un statut de co
exploitants de même pour les femmes
d'artisans pour lutter contre les
discriminations sexuelles une loi anti
sexy est à l'étude
autre changement concret à venir la
notion de chef de famille sera abolie
vis-à-vis du fisc
les taux de réversion des pensions
seront augmentés le gouvernement doit
aussi mettre en place un fonds de
garantie des princes faisait
l'inventaire et réviser le code civil
pour une telle égalité dans le mariage
enfin malgré certaines réticences
françois mitterrand envisage d'imposer
un quota minimum de femmes pour les
camps les adjectifs aux élections'' un
peu indéfini
ils répondent aux exigences que
manifestent les femmes d'aujourd'hui
autonomie égalité et dignité
pourquoi ces exigences parce que la
réalité sociale les contredit parce que
quels que soient les progrès réalisés la
situation de la femme de notre société
reste marqué par la dépendance
l'inégalité et le non respect du droit
de la personne il est inutile que je
reprenne maintenant des chiffres bien
connue de celles et de ceux qui
m'écoutent
il montre que les femmes sont
majoritaires parmi les smicards les
chômeurs les allocataires du minimum
vieillesse les personnes auxiliaires
temporaire vacataires tandis qu'elles
sont minoritaires parmi les
bénéficiaires de la formation et de la
promotion professionnelle alors qu'elles
sont majoritaires
dans la nation